ah 2013 brought us games like BioShock
Infinite and Assassin's Creed for which
everyone in their dog played before you
get stuck into this year's offerings I'm
betting I can suggest a few 2013 games
which may have flown under the radar
that are worth your attention I'm Jess
McDonald and you're watching the gist
first up I am representing all kinds of
bias by picking my personal game of the
Year brothers a tale of two sons I only
noticed this game after a friend of mine
played oh don't seem and were a tiny
review raving about it to be fair now
that it's been pretty recognized on a
girly level people are starting to take
notice but if you're still in the dark
about this one then listen up the story
is about two brothers who embark on a
journey to help their ill father each
brother is allocated a thumb stick and
an action button and it's up to you to
make sure they work together to complete
puzzles and move forward through
whatever and whoever they encounter as
the world gets darker and more corrupt
and the trials extend from bothersome to
life-threatening the game world is
beautifully detailed this story
oscillates seamlessly between joy and
tragedy and it's the kind of game that
will stick with you long after you
finished it guacamelee seemed to explode
onto the gaming scene back in April with
it spun and punctuated title and then
sort of seemed to simmer down really
quickly the ps3 Vita and PC dwelling
action platformer is as Mexican as you'd
expect and pushes beyond the boundaries
of its genre by incorporating a Mele
combat option as well as a co-op
campaign one of my favorite phrases in
the gaming world and a dimension
switching mechanic it's pretty much
exactly as cool as it sounds the player
goes between the living world and the
dead world as the luchador protagonists
request to save his one true love and
rescues the world from peril in the
process alongside all that the super
metroid s platforming is short but like
a rollercoaster is still totally worth
the ride
next up is a game you'll either put down
immediately from boredom or not be able
to stop playing don't starve embodies
quirky and then takes it all the way
away until you can't see it anymore but
that's kind of an awesome thing like
brothers a tale of two sons you won't be
hearing the dialogue spoken in any
language you recognize but the knowledge
of the survival of a floppy haired
gentleman scientist hangs in the balance
will keep you mindful of your
decision-making has anybody ever asked
you what you would do first comes on be
apocalypse find shelter gather food get
a weapon well in don't starve you need
to make that call so you're more likely
to get eaten by giant spiders or chased
by an ostrich than zombies but the point
still stands it's up to you to use
daylight to gather food and decide how
you'll prepare for nightfall and then
enjoy the pitch-black of that and try
not to get eaten or more importantly
don't starve as the game rather
blatantly suggests the giant open world
plus its charm and the desire to hold on
for just one more night will make this
one hard to put down just try not to die
another one of my favorites from this
year which didn't seem to quite get the
recognition that it deserved was the
swapper the puzzle platformer has a few
key issues with balancing difficulty but
it looks lovely and the developing story
never makes it feel like a meaningless
string of puzzles the tone of the
swapper is relatively samba you're on a
mostly abandoned Space Station with
nothing but a cloning tool in hand which
places copies of you that you can then
swap into escaping death is just a
matter of swapping out at the right time
and puzzles are generally a castle
calculation of maneuvering and planning
your moves backwards in this classical
story of nothing being quite what it
seems it's not just the puzzles but also
the ethical dilemmas which
more difficult and muddied as the tail
goes on this is a serious must place yet
another excellent side scroller which
quietly Splunk by to what the end of
this year was the dark and mad world of
puppeteer you play cooter Oh a boy who
is now a puppet and unfortunately is a
little headless luckily there are
substitute heads that the boy can find
to replace his own which as you'd expect
give him unique abilities the plot is
peppered with goddesses moon stones and
magical scissors so if it's a lovely
fantasy world you're after then look no
further property is as imaginative as it
is rare it's a side scroller that is
like nothing you'd expect from a side
scroller a hero story that avoids the
stereotypical and dull characters that
often played the genre obviously the
mechanics is sharp and the level design
integrative with unique features keeps
the platforming fresh
did you manage to get your hands on one
or more of these games throughout the
year and what did you think of them do
let me know in the comments or on my
Twitter where I'm accessing Donald be
sure to leave any more of your well
loved games from last year which
students fight get the recognition they
should've deserved
I'm just Rick Donnell and I will see you
again next week